i
bienvenidos a la entrevista de france 24
en esta emisión vamos a viajar hasta
chile para abordar el histórico
conflicto mapuche y es que durante las
últimas semanas en el marco de este
conflicto varias zonas del sur del país
han experimentado episodios de violencia
que inclusión hasta la muerte de un
comunero mapuche y en este contexto el
presidente de sebastián piñera ordenó el
estado de excepción y la militarización
de cuatro provincias del sur chileno y
es por eso que nos acompaña natividad
llanquileo ella es abogada mapuche
defensoras de derechos humanos e
integrantes de la convención
constitucional del órgano encargado de
redactar la nueva constitución chilena
natividad muchísimas gracias por tu
presencia en france 24
ahora que estás santiago muchas gracias
pero no por favor gracias a ti y
natividad preguntarte en primer lugar
cuáles son las raíces y las claves para
entender la conflictiva relación entre
el pueblo indígena mapuche y el estado
chileno y también preguntarte qué tanto
tiene que ver realmente la demanda
histórica del pueblo mapuche con el
aumento de la violencia en esta región
de chile
bueno las claves de para poder entender
este concepto tienen que ver por la
ocupación que hace el estado los
territorios de los pueblos originarios y
especialmente al pueblo mapuche y con
posterioridad también hace ocupación o
se le entrega estos territorios a las
grandes empresas extractivista por
ejemplo las forestales centrales
hidroeléctricas salmonera entre otras
que están en los territorios más ajustes
por eso es ahí donde nace toda esta esta
situación de que hoy día vivimos que es
producto de la ocupación y en la cual
obviamente que se ha ido demandando
durante mucho tiempo por parte de las
diferentes comunidades desde los 90 en
adelante que cuando yo tengo
conocimiento que se le devuelva las
tierras que fueron ocupadas y fueron
usurpadas y se le denominan por las
comunidades por parte del estado y con
posterioridad también entregada al
empresariado entonces ahí el producto de
esto también se ha ido reclamando por
parte de las diversas comunidades y en
ese sentido se han visto enfrentaba la
judicialización a la militarización y el
encarcelamiento de muchos de sus
de las personas que están en las
comunidades como asimismo también la
última muerte que se dio en el contexto
también producto de esta militarización
que tiene el estado hoy día el gobierno
tomó la decisión en realidad de
solicitar que finalmente hay un estado
de excepción constitucional como el
estado de emergencia en ese contexto en
que los últimos tiempos se provoca
también la muerte de una de las de las
personas que estaba además en su
domicilio lo que indican también una
investigación por supuesto que no ha
concluido pero que indica a sus
familiares que se encontraba en su
domicilio y ahí es donde se le da muerte
por parte de un militar perteneciente a
la fuerza al en este caso a la marina
chilena
el presidente sebastián piñera cuando
anunció este estado de emergencia y la
militarización lo que hizo fue también
referirse a grupos vinculados al
narcotráfico se refirió también al
terrorismo al crimen organizado voy a
citar sus propias palabras dijo este
estado de emergencia no se dirige contra
ningún pueblo ninguna etnia ni ningún
grupo en especial dijo piñera natividad
como interpretarse estas palabras
mira nosotros venimos con un con un
territorio ocupado que de donde yo vengo
que la provincia arauco que se solicitó
a este estado de excepción
constitucional por parte del presidente
el presidente siempre y en realidad
todos los gobiernos de turno han
insistido en que esto es un problema de
delincuencia cuando no lo es que son
demandas que vienen los pueblos
originarios y especialmente el pueblo
mapuche
señalando leales a los diferentes
gobierno y que la respuesta ha sido
absolutamente la misma no había ningún
avance respecto de estas demandas que
tienen que ver con la restitución de
tierra que tienen que ver con la
protección además del medio ambiente en
lugares donde sean instalados las
empresas forestales que hará un juego de
malleco y cautín especialmente que son
las provincias que iría también se
encuentra militarizada hay una alta
presencia forestal y que ha impedido
finalmente que las personas puedan vivir
en ese medio ambiente libre
contaminación que tanto se le ha
prometido hay una con una contaminación
tremenda producto de la familia de las
fumigaciones de estas empresas también
por supuesto las napas subterráneas
también se y o no se han ido secando por
lo tanto también hay una escasez hídrica
importante donde además del propio
estado ya en los meses de verano empieza
a repartir agua a través de camión
aljibe entonces no hay una respuesta se
enfrenta esta situación producto del
inicio que yo les señalaba que tiene que
ver finalmente con los intereses de tipo
económico que tienen especialmente las
grandes empresas dentro de los
territorios mapuches por lo tanto al
parecer el estado
está actuando a fin de proteger estos
intereses y no de proteger los intereses
que tienen las comunidades que tienen
los polis indígenas y no solamente que
van en beneficio de las propias
comunidades sino también esto va en
beneficio de todas las personas que
compartimos estos territorios que no
solamente somos mapuche o sea hay una
situación como les mencionaba de
ambiental que es compleja que no
solamente se da a nivel nacional sino
también a nivel internacional y que
nosotros también dentro de la convención
como se mencionaba nos declaramos en un
estado de emergencia climática entonces
esto tiene que ver precisamente con ese
tipo de situación
desde el otro lado lamentablemente no se
ha logrado aún a entender a pesar de que
además estamos en un proceso
constituyente donde estamos redactando
una una nueva constitución en un estado
de excepción constitucional y donde
estamos redactando esta constitución con
militares especialmente en la provincia
arauco malleco y cautín y también la
provincia de bío bío que abarca
especialmente esta zona donde hay un
alto porcentaje de personas más buzzi
esta actividad hacía precisamente
referencia a la convención
constitucional de la cual usted hace
parte y tiene otros representantes
mapuches que se han declarado con
bendecidas plurinacional podría ser una
salida al conflicto
y claro como estamos mencionando estamos
también dentro de los conceptos que se
han ido instalando desde la instalación
misma valga la redundancia de la
convención constitucional se habla de un
estado plurinacional de esto que quiere
decir y como lo han entendido en un
concepto que aún no nos hablaba no se le
ha ido dando la forma pero que sí fue
aprobado en el reglamento por el cual
hoy día no estamos rigiendo que tiene
que ver especialmente con el
reconocimiento de los derechos
individuales y colectivos de los pueblos
indígenas como asimismo también hablamos
sobre la distribución del poder sabemos
que por eso es sumamente compleja la
situación como les mencionaba porque
estamos en una en una nueva relación
supuestamente
entre el estado y los pueblos indígenas
producto de este proceso constitucional
pero cuando uno va a dialogar que es lo
que hoy estamos haciendo dentro de este
proceso responden a nuestras comunidades
con más militarización con militares en
las comunidades en los caminos y en
todos los lugares entonces bien
paradójico todo lo que está sucediendo
si bien es cierto nosotros lo vemos como
una vana es importante pero creemos que
producto de estas decisiones que tienen
los gobiernos y que han tenido los
diferentes gobiernos de turno
difícilmente podamos avanzar sin embargo
es la única oportunidad que tenemos hoy
día porque no tenemos seguía no hay una
una un diálogo por parte del gobierno
actuales con las comunidades sino más
bien como les mencionaba solamente la
respuesta que hemos tenido en los
últimos tiempo tiene que ver con mi yate
con la militarización y nosotros y como
papá en anterioridad también con una
gran presencia policial si esto también
no es de ahora todo lo que ahora se
solicitó a través de una de una norma
que también permite esta nueva esta
constitución actual por la cual nos
regimos que es señalar que en en casos
supuestamente de que esté en peligro la
seguridad interior es que se solicita un
estado de excepción constitucional y eso
es lo que ya nos hemos enfrentado en
este proceso histórico que además
estamos viviendo absolutamente ahora
natividad el conflicto mapuche va a ser
uno de los retos principales que tendrá
el próximo presidente de chile falta muy
poquito para la segunda vuelta electoral
en la que se van a enfrentar el
candidato de izquierda a gabriel boric
el de derecha josé antonio kast tienes
esperanzas en este sentido crees que
puede haber algún cambio
y la verdad es que como ya señalaba
cargamos con una historia de los
diferentes gobiernos de la
centro-izquierda que se denominan y
también tronco pierna derecha en la cual
no había respuesta pero sin duda aquí
hay que ser categórico tiene un voto no
en caso nos va a permitir más avanzar
que otro porque tenemos un candidato que
es tremendamente racista que es clasista
que es ha hecho apología al odio ya
todos los demás en contra de personas
migrantes hay una situación viejo queja
por parte de uno de los candidatos que
difícilmente va a poder avanzar si es
que fuera elegido
y contanos estábamos hablando
previamente de la constituyente cómo es
la convivencia al interior de esta
convención especialmente con los
partidos tradicionales hay
discriminación
bueno los partidos tradicionales tienen
su forma de operar que muchas veces no
compartimos ha sido a veces así una
situación muy difícil como de poder
entendernos porque además somos culturas
distintas las cuales estamos
acostumbrados a hacer política de una
forma de igualdad de condiciones de
estar de igual a igual con con largas
conversa pero acá no encontramos también
con un tema que es mucho más rápido y
que si bien es cierto estuvimos en la
primera etapa que fue de redacción del
reglamento pudimos avanzar hacia su
concepto como mencionaba respecto de la
plurinacionalidad y que fueran
entendiendo también que los pueblos
indígenas se relacionan de forma
distinta
creemos que aún falta mucho para
aprender también por parte de los
diferentes partidos políticos porque
siempre quieren sumarnos a su espacio
cosas que muchas veces nosotros no
permitimos porque nuestras realidades
son muy distintas a nuestras realidades
tienen que ver con la defensa de
territorio con la defensa de derechos
colectivos derechos individuales pero
qué
y esperamos obviamente que hayan
aprendido algo durante todos estos meses
que llevamos en la convención y si no
sería muy lamentable para este país
tener que salir de esta convención
constitucional de la misma forma en la
cual ingresamos sería la verdad que
sería un completo desastre si eso
sucediera digamos y sé que no le
hubieran haber dio nada respecto a este
proceso porque nosotros también le hemos
dejado con harto tiempo con alta
paciencia cómo explicar también nuestras
formas de vida cuáles son nuestras
demandas y además porque nosotros hemos
señalado nosotros no partimos de un
ejemplar aún como se ha reiterado en
muchas ocasiones sino más bien como
pueblo originario partimos con un
tratado internacional de derechos
humanos como el convenio 169 que
recuerdan los derechos de los pueblos
indígenas como asimismo la declaración
de naciones unidas respecto a los
derechos de los pueblos indígenas
entonces ya están los derecho ahora
tenemos que ver como recuerda mos esos
derechos en este nuevo texto
institucional entonces esto también lo
hemos tenido que
señalar una y otra vez porque nos dicen
bueno nosotros partimos del auge blanco
bueno hay otros límites también como son
los tratados internacionales y eso
siempre hay que estarlo señalando las
diferentes discusiones que vamos dando
la mayoría del pp si natividad
llanquileo muchísimas gracias por tu
presencia en la entrevista de france 24
muchas gracias pues por favor a usted
nuevamente ya nuestra audiencia como
siempre le invitamos a continuar
informándose en el resto de nuestra
programación y también en france mit y
cuatro.com gracias por acompañarnos y
sigan con nosotros
[Música]